[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
seeler
guten abend in allen jedes bisschen
hoffnung zählt doppelt an einem weiteren
tag an dem die schlimmen nachrichten aus
der ukraine nicht enden wollen einem
weiteren tag wie dem heute es gibt eine
einzige meldung heute in die sich so
etwas wie hoffnung
hineinlesen ließe und die kommt aus der
türkei am donnerstag wollen sich dort
die außenminister russlands und der
ukraine treffen es wäre das erste solche
treffen seit wochen es fände stadt vor
dem hintergrund weiterer schwerer
russische attacken britische
geheimdienstkreise sagen russland greife
ähnlich wie im tschetschenien krieg und
wie in syrien dicht besiedelte gebiete
an wir beginnen heute abend mit kalk
felix jochens und einem ersten überblick
sie wollen einfach nur raus aus der
kampfzone
zivilisten auf der flucht über unsichere
wege
in den städten zu bleiben keine option
archiv am morgen hier ist niemand mehr
sicher dimitri und seine frau waren zu
hause als eine rakete ihren wohnkomplex
traf wir waren im flur als es passierte
wir haben nicht gesehen wo genau die
rakete einschlug aber ich glaube sie
traf den vierten stock unter uns sofort
fing alles an zu brennen und
auseinanderzufallen durch den rauch
konnte man fast nichts mehr sehen
teilweise krachte der boden ein wir sind
dann irgendwie raus gekrochen es gab
tote wir hatten glück sichere routen
eröffnen um zivilisten aus dem
kampfgebiet zu bringen russland schlägt
am morgen insgesamt sechs korridore vor
von kiew nach gomel von mario pohl nach
rostov am don und sakura von rajeev nach
belgorod und von sumy nach belgrad und
poltawa 4 dieser routen würden
ukrainische zivilisten also nach
russland oder belarus führen und das ist
für die ukrainische seite nicht
annehmbar
das ist eine nicht akzeptable option
diese humanitären korridoren nach
russland und belarus zu öffnen unser
volk auf die mehr wie vor ort und kiew
wird nicht nach belarus gehen um später
nach russland zu gehen
das einrichten von flugkorridoren
hauptthema heute beim dritten treffen
der unterhändler aus kiew und moskau im
polnisch belarussischen grenzgebiet man
hört von keinen nennenswerten
fortschritte in dem von russland
eroberten gebieten kommt es heute wieder
zu protesten in carson rufen sie den
besatzern geht nach hause zu die antwort
warnschüsse
und den milito polsingen die bürger ihre
nationalhymne
[Musik]
das russische verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlicht heute diese bilder panzer
die weiter vorrücken in kiew bereitet
man sich darauf vor
anabel ist eigentlich tanzlehrerin
dieser tage stopft die junge frau
sandsäcke für die straßensperren im
zentrum der stadt kiew zu verlassen
kommt für sie nicht in frage
ist das unser land und zweitens haben
wir keine verwandten außerhalb pearce
und drittens glauben wir an unsere
streitkräfte und an unsere verteidigung
eine entspannung der lage durch
verhandlungen ist nicht in sicht und so
lange das so bleibt werden die waffen
weiter das reden übernehmen
aus der heftig umkämpften großstadt
kharkiv ist maria war jetzt bei uns
dieses politikwissenschaftlerin frau auf
dem guten abend
den guten abend die behörden bei ihnen
melden
133 getöteten zivilisten in den letzten
tagen darunter fünf kinder und zwei
tagen schwere angriffe der russischen
armee wie haben wir uns ihren tag
aktuell vorzustellen in so einer
situation in kharkiv
also in kharkiv wer ständig bombardiert
von russischen kampfflugzeugen die ganze
nacht über den fang normalerweise am
abend an und da werden wohngebiete
bombardiert dass dort die ganze nacht
durch und am frühen morgen da kommt dann
immer diese schrecklichen berichte wie
viele menschen in der nacht noch getötet
worden sind letzte nacht starben zehn
menschen
das ist mal nicht die tatsächliche zahl
denn viele menschen sind noch begraben
unter dem geröll in den zerstörten
häusern und wir bekommen die genauen
zahlen erst viel später
aber im allgemeinen ist es so dass bis
jetzt mehr als 100 menschen gestorben
sind in kharkiv
und das ist eine ganz schreckliche
situation denn darunter sind auch kinder
und ganze familien ist uns berichtet
worden
sind getötet worden zum beispiel eine
familie die versuchte im auto aus der
stadt zu entkommen wie versuchen sie
denn unter diesen umständen zumindest
irgendwie sicherheit zu finden haben sie
einen bunker haben sie irgendeinen
sicheren ort an den sie gehen können
wenn denn wieder eine weitere nacht des
bombardements folgt
ich bleibe einfach in meiner wohnung und
verstecken sich im flur denn da habe ich
zwei wände zwischen mir und der straße
also wenn dann granat einstiege sind
dann hoffe ich dass
die granatsplitter nicht in die wohnung
einkommen oder nur die äußeren wände
zerstören
wir sehen im moment zumindest haben sie
strom wir sehen aber auch hinter ihnen
so ein bisschen die stadt liegt
praktisch komplett im dunkeln im moment
können sie uns ein bisschen die
versorgungslage beschreiben wie sieht's
aus mit wasser mit lebensmitteln aktuell
bei hin
die stadt ist jetzt völlig verdunkelt
und nach drei oder vier uhr nachmittags
sieht man keine menschen mehr auf der
straße normalerweise findet man hunderte
von menschen auf der straße um diese
tageszeit aber jetzt ist es so dass die
menschen sich verstecken die gehen nur
am morgen mal raus um lebensmittel zu
bekommen die versorgung ist auch nicht
so gut es gibt zu wenig darum es mittel
und auch bin ich medikamente es gibt
noch irgendwo wasser und elektrizität
aber es gibt genauso häuser ohne strom
und ich selber war jetzt drei tage lang
ohne strom
jetzt ist der strom wieder da aber ich
weiß nicht wann ich die elektrizität wie
der frühere denn die russischen
kampfflugzeuge die zielen auf kritische
infrastruktur abheben stromwerke
fernsehsender und kraftwerke das heißt
in jedem moment kann es sein dass die
stadt überhaupt keine heizung mehr hat
denn draußen ist es ja doch sehr sehr
kalt und was die lebensmittelversorgung
angeht da gibt es knappheit die menschen
können eigentlich nur noch das bekommen
was es noch in den regalen des
supermarktes gibt salz da überhaupt noch
etwas ist es ist sehr schwierig
irgendetwas für ältere menschen zu
finden oder menschen die besondere
bedürfnisse haben was die nahrung angeht
eine millionenstadt vor einer weiteren
mutmaßlich schlimme nacht ragip direkt
von dort maria wewer frau auf der wahl
herzlichen dank für diese schilderungen
heute abend bei uns und alles gute für
sie
ich danke ihnen es war mir eine freude
maria auf der wahl will ausharren das
gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet sie weiß welche gefahr
droht sie verfolgt genau die bilder aus
ihrem land unter beschuss aus der
ukraine gehen heute auch andere bilder
um die welt da fasst sich jemand ein
herz um alle anderen in dem bunker für
ein paar momente an die friedliche zeit
zu erinnern die noch nicht einmal zwei
wochen her ist es ist jemand der selbst
angst hat und selbst noch sehr klein ist
[Musik]
applaus für die kleine an denen ja nur
ein lied und gleichzeitig so viel mehr
andreas weise zeigt uns jetzt die
situation der menschen in einem vorort
von kiew der bis vor ein paar tagen als
besonders attraktive wohngegend galt
speziell für junge familien und in dem
für die noch nicht geflüchtet die zeit
knapp wird
es geht nur noch zu fuß
unterhalb einer zerstörten brücke
überqueren sie den kleinen fluss der so
heißt wie ihr ort
nordwestlich von kiew
entsetzt von dem was sie erlebt haben
erschöpft von den letzten tagen
gestern waren die schwersten
bombardements die blitze und der lärm
waren so furchtbar und das ganze haus
wackelte
[Musik]
ich saß mit meinen kindern die halbe
nacht im flur weil das der sicherste
platz ist und dann entschied ich dass es
jetzt genug ist
und so wie tausende andere auspackte
anastasija ein paar sachen zusammen
sucht schutz außerhalb des vorortes von
kiel
es gab eine erklärung des bürgermeisters
und er sagte dass das jetzt unsere
letzte chance sein den ort zu verlassen
er sagte dass es hier noch heftige
kämpfe geben wird und es besser zeit zu
gehen
die leute fliehen mit ihren haustieren
mit ihrem hab und gut sie nehmen mit was
sie tragen können
einige stadtteile sind wohl schon
eingekreist
unübersehbar hier wurde heftig gekämpft
über ihn führt einer der wege nach kiew
dem ziel der russischen angreifer
teile von alpin sollen sie schon
eingenommen haben doch nach eigenen
angaben kontrollieren die ukraine noch
gut 70 prozent des stadtgebietes wenn
dieser vor ort fällt ist einer der wege
nach tier frei
zurzeit kämpfen unsere leute in buch
ihre bienen und horst thoma ich kann nur
sagen dass wir jetzt nicht verlassen
werden wir kämpfen um jedes haus jede
straße jeden check point wenn es sein
muss bis zum tod
nach den heftigen angriffen auf ihr team
gestern wollen immer mehr der
ursprüngliche über 60.000 einwohner die
stadt verlassen
sie nutzen die wenigen ruhigen momente
es könnte die ruhe vor dem nächsten
vielleicht noch heftigeren angriff sein
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine und
jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen dann
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine hier ist
die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
alle informationen auch noch mal im
internet oder im zdf text
es ist eine gerade eine situation mit
gravierenden folgen auch für rund 145
millionen russinnen und russen folgen
die zum teil noch überhaupt nicht
absehbar sind und dabei ergibt sich die
paradoxe situation dass viele menschen
in russland wohl gar nicht wissen was da
gerade vor sich geht und warum ihr land
international
katastrophale schlagzeilen macht in
russland selbst kann schon die erwähnung
des wortes krieg in den medien
schwerwiegende folgen haben für die das
wort benutzen ein neues mediengesetz
droht mit härtesten strafen wie andere
sender auch hat das zdf die
berichterstattung seiner korrespondenten
aus moskau vorerst ausgesetzt christian
sam ist deshalb hier bei uns christian
guten abend heute ist feiertag in
russland wie läuft denn da jetzt das
leben
heute war gewissermaßen einen brückentag
nach dem wochenende morgen ist der
feiertag der weltfrauentag und der wird
es traditionell in russland gefeiert die
männer beschenkten die frauen und viele
haben jetzt die freien tage genutzt
sofern sie das konnten sind raus aus der
stadt und werden morgen diesen tag
begehen einerseits andererseits hat die
sprecherin des inhaftierten
kremlkritikers nav allen die jetzt dazu
aufgerufen dass die frauen morgen auf
die straße gehen sollen und gegen
unbedingt um gegen diesen krieg zu
demonstrieren sie sagt ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass es eine frau in
russland gibt die diesen krieg will
also auf der einen seite feiertag das
klingt jetzt erst mal nach relativer
normalität ist denn auf den straßen in
russland bei den menschen zu merken dass
da etwas nicht stimmt zum beispiel beim
geld gibt es da lange schlangen gibt es
da probleme zu bezahlen aktuell
ja man merkt dass immer wieder wir haben
das in den letzten tagen vor allem in
moskau immer wieder gesehen schlangen an
den geldautomaten das ist nicht die
ganze zeit das ist nicht flächendeckend
das ist immer mal wieder zu bestimmten
zeiten und auch unterschiedlich von bank
zu bank da kriegen die menschen das mit
und dann natürlich wenn sie die
wechselkurse an den wechselstuben sehen
und die sorge ist doch sehr groß um die
eigene währung um den rubel dass der
irgendwann nichts mehr wert ist und
viele haben jetzt auch schon vorher
versucht das geld von der bank zu holen
ihr gehalt zu holen und in russland sind
shopping center auch sehr beliebt und
man sieht dort jetzt die ganzen
internationalen läden die ganzen
internationalen marken die sich
zurückziehen aus russland finden findet
dann finden ausverkäufe stadt die
menschen gehen denn diese shopping
center um noch die letzten produkte sich
irgendwie zu krallen auch große
möbelhäuser internationale der weg gehen
da gab's eine riesenschlange weil man
versucht die letzten bestellungen zu
machen und so lange diese firmen noch da
sind irgendwas rauszuziehen weil den
menschen klar ist wenn die weg sind
werden sie so schnell diese produkte
nicht mehr kriegen ist denn den menschen
auch klar oder kann man sagen wie viel
den menschen in russland aktuell klar
ist über die gründe für all das
ich glaube es sehr unterschiedlich vor
allem die älteren menschen die vor allem
das staatsfernsehen gucken wo die
propaganda immer wieder propagiert wird
dass dieser konflikt nötig ist mit dem
nachbarn ukraine
das hört man dann noch immer wieder wenn
wir unsere straßen umfragen gemacht
haben dass dieses argument was im
staatsfernsehen kommt dass das auch
immer wieder wiederholt wird bei den
jüngeren sieht das anders aus die auch
versuchen andere medien zu konsumieren
aber auch das wird ja immer schwieriger
in russland dem neuen mediengesetzen die
medien in russland jetzt massiv unter
druck zeitungen wie die nowaja gaseta
die hatten ein sehr breites angebot auf
ihrer internetseite was diesen konflikt
angeht auch tv duft und die haben ihn
die inhalte von der seite gelöscht und
dvd arbeitet jetzt gar nicht mehr
christiansen der zdf russland
korrespondent herzlichen dank für diese
einordnung heute abend
der russische energiesektor ist sehr
wichtig für die wirtschaft des landes
und er ist sehr wichtig für uns das war
jahrelang ein deal jetzt ist es ein
problem die energielieferungen aus
russland stehen bislang nicht im zentrum
der sanktionen des westens dabei wären
einnahmeausfälle dort sehr hart für die
regierung sie wären aber eben auch sehr
hart für alle hier bei uns hören sie auf
russisches öl zu kaufen appelliert die
ukrainische regierung wenn wir das täten
würde es europas wärmeerzeugung
mobilität stromversorgung und industrie
treffen sagt der bundeskanzler
mit anderen worten dann gingen hier die
lichter aus schon jetzt zeigt sich was
der krieg mit den preisen macht
elisabeth schmidt hat mehr dazu
der ein oder andere autofahrer reibt
sich die augen ein liter diesel kostet
auch an dieser tankstelle in hannover
heute mehr als zwei euro und übersteigt
damit den preis für super e10 der
ölpreis klettert zu wochenbeginn auf den
höchsten stand seit 14 jahren und der
preis für erdgas ist seit beginn des
ukraine krieges um mehr als 60 prozent
gestiegen
das was wir im moment an den märkten
serien preises in meiner meinung nach
keine panikkäufe man sucht im moment
alternativen für russland obwohl
russland weiterhin liefert die mengen
die wir setzen müssen sind schon
ziemlich groß und deswegen versucht man
jetzt am markt aufzukaufen was geht
deutschland bezieht aus russland 55
prozent des erdgases 35
rund 50 prozent der kohle die
abhängigkeit vom kreml machthaber ist
enorm wir müssen wissen dass wenn wir
die gas und öl importe weiter betreiben
dann finanzieren wir auf rekordniveau
den krieg von putin gegen das
ukrainische volk mit annähernd eine
milliarde dollar pro tag das kann nicht
sein damit konterkarieren wir unsere
eigenen sanktionen die usa fordern
bereits ein öl-embargo gegen russland
die bundesregierung lehnt dies bislang
ab die eu will sich morgen dazu äußern
heute nur so viel
wir müssen uns breiter aufstellen und
von russland unabhängig machen auf
verlässliche lieferanten setzen vor
allem lng und pipeline dar
ln sie also liquified natural gas zu
deutsch verflüssigtes erdgas das per
schiff aus den usa asien oder nordafrika
nach europa kommt überall in europa gibt
es bereits flüssiggas an lande stellen
nur in deutschland nicht europa baut
weiter terminals in deutschland befinden
sich drei standorte in der planungsphase
brunsbüttel willems hafen und stade doch
auch stade wird wohl frühestens 2026 an
den start gehen können deutschland muss
sich kurzfristig auf seine nachbarländer
verlassen wir befinden uns in einer art
wirtschaftskrieg und das heißt auch dass
wir eine sehr sehr viel enger verzahnte
zusammenarbeit in europa brauchen dass
wir
gemeinsam quasi schauen müssen welche
optionen wir haben auf russisches gas zu
verzichten heißt aber auch lng tanker
aus den usa werden bald wohl häufiger
umweltschädliches fracking erdgas nach
europa bringen
langfristig sollen terminals wie das
geplante in stade klimafreundlichen
wasserstoff importieren kurzfristig
scheint aber die devise zu lauten
energie sicherheit geht vor klimaschutz
bringen davon geht man noch mit dazu an
der frankfurter börse frank versagen
denn die wirtschaftsexperten ist dann zu
erwarten dass das jetzt immer so weiter
geht immer höhere preise das ist so
kommen wird dafür spricht was heute im
laufe des tages auch passierte der
ölkonzern shell hat wegen der
angespannten marktlage den verkauf von
heizöl und diesel an einige großkunden
in deutschland vorerst eingeschränkt
also angebotsverknappung allerdings muss
man wissen dass diese einschränkung nur
für neue abnehmer gilt shell
argumentierte heute dass man so hoffe
die bereits bestehenden langfristigen
verpflichtungen gegenüber seinen kunden
erfüllen zu können in deutschland läuft
das geschäft größtenteils über diese
langfristigen verträge heißt sprit wird
erstmal nicht knapp werden aber die
preise an den tankstellen werden bei
solchen alarmzeichen natürlich auch
nicht sinken jetzt gibt es eine
diskussion es gibt forderungen es gibt
drohungen auch die im raum stehen die
energielieferungen aus russland quasi
komplett zu stoppen wenn das tatsächlich
geschehe was wären die folgen für uns
hier in deutschland für verbraucher und
industrie russlands gas und
öllieferungen zu ersetzen ist nicht
unmöglich aber verdammt schwer wir haben
es ja eben schon gehört vor allem in der
kürze die preise für eben jene fossilen
energieträger würden weiter drastisch
steigen ich las heute eine
analystenmeinung der preis der freiheit
würde demnach bei 200 dollar je barrel
liegen also wenn die welt kein
russisches öl mehr nutzen würde je
weiter der preis steigt desto mehr
unternehmen kämen hierzulande in
bedrängnis um das möglichst zu
verhindern hat bundesfinanzminister
lindner ja bereits finanzielle
unterstützung signalisiert etwas
ähnliches müsste spätestens dann auch
für die endverbraucher geben von
gaspreis deckel ist er unter anderem
bereits die rede parallel dazu läuft
eben jene internationale beschaffungs
diplomatie auf hochtouren wer kann
russland kurzfristig ersetzen diese
frage ist eben derzeit noch völlig offen
frank wittmann in frankfurt dankeschön
wird diese analyse und jetzt weitere
wichtige nachrichten zum russischen
krieg in der ukraine und hanna du hast
den überblick über die lage in der
ukraine zu beraten kamen heute
bundeskanzler scholz us präsident biden
frankreichs staatschef makro und der
britische premier johnson zu einer video
konferenz zusammen nach den beratungen
forderten sie russland erneut zu einem
sofortigen rückzug aus der ukraine auf
das weiße haus teilte mit dass die
staats und regierungschefs ihre
entschlossenheit bekräftigt hätten die
kosten für russland weiter zu erhöhen
die usa haben den baltischen staaten den
schutz der nato zugesichert bei seinem
besuch in litauen kündigte us
außenminister linken außerdem an 400
zusätzliche soldaten in das land zu
verlegen
litauens staatspräsidentin seda warnte
wegen der rücksichtslosen aggression
russlands vor einer langfristigen
bedrohung der europäischen sicherheit
in der vergangenen woche hatten die
ukraine moldau und georgien ihren
beitritt zur eu beantragt heute nun hat
die europäische union die prüfung der
anträge eingeleitet zunächst soll die
europäische kommission eine
stellungnahme dazu abgeben da sagte der
chef der europäischen des europäischen
rates der eu beitrittsprozess dauert in
der regel mehrere jahre
nach einer dringlichkeit der ukraine
muss sich russland seit heute vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof in den haag
verantworten
die ukrainische regierung wirft russland
völkermord vor der gerichtshof müsse so
schnell wie möglich ein ende der
kampfhandlungen anordnen forderte ein
vertreter der ukraine russland gibt der
anhörung fern
radio russki ist das einzig
russischsprachige radioprogramm in
deutschland seit 18 jahren in berlin auf
ukw 97 2 und im internet service
nachrichten unterhaltung nicht nur für
mehrere hunderttausend staatsbürger aus
russland und der ukraine in deutschland
sondern auch für geschätzt über zwei
millionen russischsprachige menschen bei
uns hier in diesem land vermutlich war
ein sender wie radio roski noch nie so
wichtig wie gerade jetzt und
gleichzeitig sitzt er jetzt zwischen
allen stühlen stefanie groß berichtet
bei radio russki berlin berichten sie
über den krieg in der ukraine auf
russisch nachrichten für die in russland
seit kurzem gefängnis droht bis zu 15
jahre
[Musik]
wir haben und keine wir haben großen wir
haben letten wir haben kasachen wir
haben einen kollegen aus usbekistan alle
verbindet die russische sprache auch
eine zeitung gestaltet das team seit ein
paar tagen heißt diese nicht mehr roski
sondern redaktion berlin und auch den
radiosender wollen sie umbenennen denn
was russisch klingt die plötzlich unter
generalverdacht dem unabhängigen medium
brachen werbekunden weg diese probleme
sind nichts im vergleich zu dem was
jetzt eine kleine passiert wobei ist
jetzt ja also man könnte es schon
hexenjagd nennen eigentlich langsam was
jetzt mit wussten hier passiert was mit
billa rosen hier passiert die
redakteurin radmila applebaum ist in der
ukraine geboren mit ihren kindern
spricht sie russisch auf der straße wird
das nun zum problem ich hab sofort die
blicke gesehen von fremden passanten und
ist auch chancen
das ist natürlich schon schwierig ich
kann ja nicht jeder klient hallo ich
habe damit nichts zu tun mindestens
200.000 russischsprachige menschen leben
in berlin im autoradio spielte roski
berlin ein ukrainisches liebeslied
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt alle an die front alle
musiker alle fußballer die sind jetzt
alle in camouflage umgehen an die front
maria genannt masche hatte viele
freundschaftliche kontakte nach russland
das ist nun vorbei viele glauben putins
propaganda
deshalb so eine kleine kleine sind nicht
mehr so in seinen virtuellen friedhof
eigentlich nach wo ich mich tagtäglich
von von
freunden verabschieden so von menschen
die mir ganz mietbaren von menschen mit
denen ich sehr lange kontakt hatte die
russische sprache der community in
berlin dagegen rückt zusammen der
georgier kenia ti bringt spenden zur
ukrainischen grenze
wir haben nichts zu essen das gibt einen
kollaps drüben wir brauchen unbedingt
konserven und medizin konserven medizin
nochmal konserven medizin auch seine
familie spricht russisch die kinder
wurden deshalb in der schule schon
gemobbt so sind sie in vielfacher weise
von putins krieg betroffen und werden
für ein system mit verantwortlich
gemacht vor dem sie einst aus gutem
grund geflohen sind
eine weitere herausforderung in diesen
zeiten voller herausforderungen wenn
sich menschen nicht mehr trauen in
deutschland russisch zu sprechen ist
niemandem in der ukraine geholfen
so hanna guckt jetzt noch auf weitere
wichtige nachrichten die gab's nämlich
heute auch und wir beginnen mit corona
und weiteren lockerungen so müssen
schüler in hessen mecklenburg vorpommern
sachsen und sachsen anhalt seit heute im
unterricht keine masken ertragen
gleichzeitig steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland im
wochenvergleich und zwar auf 78 1428 das
sind laut robert koch institut und
16.000 mehr als vor einer woche und auch
die sieben tage inzidenz steigt
mittlerweile seit fünf tagen auf 1.200
59,2
frauen in deutschland haben auch im
vergangenen jahr weniger verdient als
männer im schnitt waren es 18 prozent
pro stunde das hat das statistische
bundesamt zum heutigen equal pay day
berechnet die lohnlücke hat vor allem
strukturelle gründe frauen arbeiten
häufiger in schlecht bezahlten berufen
und erreichen seltener
führungspositionen aber auch bei
vergleichbare arbeit und qualifikation
verdienen frauen weniger als ihre
männlichen kollegen dann sind das sechs
prozent
bei der frühjahrsvollversammlung der
deutschen bischofskonferenz steht neben
dem kampf gegen sexuellen missbrauch und
der debatte über innerkirchliche
reformen
außerdem der ukraine krieg im zentrum zu
beginn der viertägigen beratungen ging
es auch um die zukunft des umstrittenen
kölner kardinals woelki der vorsitzende
der deutschen bischofskonferenz bätzing
forderte den vatikan auf schnell über
dessen rücktrittsangebot zu entscheiden
am abend gab es dann einen
eröffnungsgottesdienst mit einem gebet
für frieden in der ukraine
[Musik]
und das war dieser montag hier bei uns
im heute schon mal nach der hinweis auf
unser heute-journal update darin ein
gespräch mit dem generalsekretär des
deutschen roten kreuzes der flucht
korridore kritisch sieht warum sehen sie
hier gegen 05 von uns beiden war es das
für heute guten abend
[Musik]
guten abend heute möchte ich ihnen
einmal zeigen wie unterschiedliche
temperaturen empfinden zum beispiel in
belm heute mittag da gab es bei
strahlenden sonnenschein vier grad das
kam uns aber wie sieben grad vor ganz
anders in wunstorf in der nähe von
hannover da kam uns die null grad im
nebel vj -2 grad vor auf dem großen
arber im bayerischen wald schneite es
und es fehlte ein richtig kräftiger
nordostwind und deswegen kam uns die
show tiefen minus elf grad minus 18 grad
vor von westen kommen jetzt tiefs heran
die kommen aber nicht so richtig durch
und das liegt an den hochs martin und
nur so bleibt es bei uns vorläufig noch
kalt heute nacht wird es frostig da
sinken die temperaturen auf minus ein
bis minus zehn grad meist ist es klar
nur im osten bildet sich auch mal etwas
nebel oder es gibt hochnebel der wind
legt morgen zu es ist ein ost- bis
südostwind nebel und hochnebel haben
wenig chancen und häufig scheint die
sonne so steigen die temperaturen morgen
auf vier bis zwölf grad das wird aber
jetzt in den nächsten tagen immer milder
am freitag erwarten uns höchst
temperaturen von sieben grad auf rügen
und 17 grad am niederrhein am wetter
ändert sich derweil wenig anfänglich
gibt es vielleicht mal ein bisschen
nebel dann aber strahlenden sonnenschein
und allenfalls am freitag werden die
wolken dann von westen etwas dichter
guten abend